[موسيقى]
الاف الفتيات في الهند حرم عليهن الزواج
من بقيه البشر بعدما اجبرنا على الالتحاق
بمعابد للاستغلال الجنسي وخدمه الكهنه فما
السبب وراء هذا التقليد المتوارث منذ قرون
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
في جنوب الهند تقام هنا واحده من اقدم
الممارسات الجنسيه
الديفاداسي فتيات صغيرات كرست حياتهن
بالاجبار لخدمه المعابد والكهنه والالهه
الهندوسيه فهؤلاء التحقنا بهذه المعابد
قبل ان يبلغنا العاشره وشرعنا في تعلم
طقوس الموسيقى ورقصه الاوديسي وفرض عليهن
القيام بالواجبات التقليديه لزوجه
الهندوسيه
وتمتعنا سابقا بمركز اجتماعي مرموق داخل
المجتمع الهندسي لكن لم تقتصر ادوارهن على
ذلك بل اقحمنا في دائره من الاستغلال
الجنسي وانجبنا الاطفال من الكهنه وكبار
المسؤولين بحجه ان حياتهن كرست للالهه
التي تعتبر الهه الخصوبه لدى الهندوس عاده
يوحد بفتيات الديفاداس جنسيا في بدايه
حياتهن الى رجل كبير السن يجود بالاموال
على اسر الفتيات ويغدق عليهن الهدايا
والمجوهرات
مثلا واحده من الاف الفتيات التي تعرضنا
للاستغلال الجنسي
صنائرى مريم
[تصفيق]
رغم الطبيعه الماساويه لهذه الطقوس الا ان
البعض هنا في الهند لا يزال مقتنعا بها
وبمواصله العمل بها ففي قريه سونداتي مثلا
التي يوجد بها معبد للالهه الى ما العديد
من العائلات تعتقد ان وجود ديفاداسي ضمن
الاسر يحميهم من الشرور ويجلب لهم الحظ
السعيد
السكان هنا توارث هذه الممارسات لمئات
السنين لكن في عام
حضرت الهند هذه الطقوس على المستوى الوطني
الا ان تقارير اللجنه الهنديه لحقوق
الانسان تفيد بوجود اكثر من 70 الف
ديفاداسي حتى اليوم في ولايه كرنتاكا
وحدها
[موسيقى]
العديد من فتيات الديفاداسي تحررنا من هذه
العبوديه والتحقنا بمنظمات اجتماعيه
لمساعدتهن على التعافي والانخراط في
المجتمع بشكل صحي وايجاد عمل شرعي لهن
بطئ نمبر
في المقابل ما زالت هناك فتيات محررات لم
تتحسن حياتهن واصبحنا بلا اي مصدر للعيش
شاركونا ارائكم هل سمعتم عن طقوس تشبه
تقليداي من قبل
[موسيقى]